coraline first encounters the cat as she
explores the grounds of her new home
where she sees it sitting on walls and
tree stumps at first she tried to play
with it but whenever she approached it
ran away but the two would soon be
forced to work together to counter a
very powerful ancient evil known as the
beldam the cat has become one of the
most infamous and mysterious characters
among coraline fans the subject of
countless wild theories and speculations
the cat is actually the reincarnation of
the bell dam's ex-lover how there's
possibly two cats trapped in one body
but both of them are not real cats one
of them is the spirit of wyby's
grandma's father and the other one is
either the son of the other mother or
the spirit of the other world even if
the cat does work for the bell dam he
could still be related to the lovett
family well i do find those ideas a
little bit uh what's the right word
unhinged i do have my own ideas about
who this feisty feline really is so to
explore those let's take a look at the
history of the cat from the coraline
novel to learn about the cat's
connections to witchcraft why he can
talk in the belldem's world and why the
beldam fears this creature stick around
to the end of this video this video is
sponsored by audible
welcome to horror history although i'm
sure you don't need a horror history
lesson seeing as how you're the expert
on such things today we're talking about
the cat from the novel coraline however
this cat may have actually had an
appearance before that retroactively the
movie adaptation of coraline is directed
by henry selleck who also directed the
1993 movie the nightmare before
christmas both movies are stop motion
animation so they probably reused the
same model or made a very similar model
in coraline as an easter egg in coraline
the cat gets a voice courtesy of voice
actor keith david david has a very deep
silky voice and he's usually known for
playing some kind of monster or badass
mercenary but he'll occasionally voice a
creepy cat like in once upon a time in
wonderland or coraline to unravel the
mystery of the black cat we first need
to understand its history so let's take
it back to before coraline entered the
picture
[Music]
like coraline there is only one cat who
travels back and forth between the real
world and the other world the realm
created by the bell dam to try to trick
children into falling into her trap for
this reason the cat is the only
character from coraline's world who has
no other world counterparts between this
and the fact that the cat can talk while
in the bell dams world i don't think
that this cat was always just a cat one
of the more prominent examples of a
black cat culture comes from greek
mythology galinthius was a servant of
the greek goddess hera hera wanted to
prevent the birth of this dude named
heracles but galinthius ruined this plan
by saying that the baby had already been
born so as punishment tara turned
golemthius into a black cat it's
possible something along these lines
happened before the events of coraline
the cat was probably a human who snuck
into the other world and interfered with
the beldam's plan to steal the soul of a
kit at one point he even tells coraline
that he walked into the other world just
like she did unable to steal his soul
and unable to get her claws on him to
kill him the beldam was only able to use
her magic to turn him into a cat like
the ghost children who i discussed in a
previous horror history details of his
old wife like his name faded from memory
as time passed in the movie we even see
that the cat has a chunk of his ear
missing as if that was the only body
part that the bell down was able to get
her sharp claws on before he scampered
away when coraline encounters the cat in
the other world for the first time he
wishes her a good afternoon and she
thinks its voice sounded like the voice
at the back of her head the voice that
she thought words in but a man's voice
not a girl's so if the voice didn't
actually sound like her she must have
been talking about the cadence which is
why i think that the cat was someone
that wandered into the other world just
like horun but there's a lot more to it
than that i swear i'm not one of those
unhinged coralline youtubers in the
ancient greek tales galinthius was taken
in by another greek deity hecate the
goddess of witchcraft and death this is
likely the origin of the trope that's
still with us today where black cats and
witches are commonly associated with
each other i've talked a little bit in
my other videos about how coraline
herself has witch-like properties when
miss [ __ ] reads coraline's tea leaves
the two neighbor women determine that
she has danger in her future and give
her a stone with a hole in it they don't
explicitly describe what it is but it's
clearly supposed to be an adder stone
sometimes known as a witch stone an
artifact said to give the user magic
protections when coraline looks through
her dresser in the other world one of
the outfits she discovers is a witch
costume and her father has a song about
her where he refers to her as his
twitchy witchy girl in the movie
coraline even pretends to have a magic
dowsing rod and wybee refers to her as a
water witch well
great to meet a michigan water witch
coraline doesn't get along with the cat
much at first he's described as a
haughty black cat meaning that he's
arrogantly superior and disdainful he
has no satisfying answer for her as to
why he can talk and when she tells him
that cats can't talk at home he
sarcastically states that she's the
expert and he's only a cat coraline
tells him that they could be friends but
he responds by telling her we could be
rare specimens of an exotic breed of
african dancing elephants but we're not
at least it added cattley after darting
a brief look at coraline i'm not before
this first conversation ends she asked
the cat what his name is he insists that
cats do not have names they know who
they are we've seen something like this
before here in horror history when i
covered valic from the conjuring
franchise i explained how in religions
like christianity naming a creature
gives the person a dominion over it
lorraine warren needs to discover
vallec's name in order to address it and
banish it back to hell witches and by
association of their black cats are
often seen as evil or threatening in
major religions so by not having a name
the cat makes it harder for anyone to
gain power over it by calling or
summoning it there's even a conversation
later where the cat points out that
calling for a cat is pointless akin to
calling a whirlwind black cats have a
long history of being links to the
supernatural or spiritual ancient
egyptians worshiped the goddess bastet
who had a black cat's head and they
built huge cat monuments during the
middle ages when major religions that we
know today were becoming dominant
witchcraft was seen as a sign of
anti-religion and cats were seen as a
sign of bad luck more recently made a
parade described a black cat who planned
to burn down its city with a backpack
full of fireworks sounds terrifying and
this is why dogs are better the cat
commends coraline on bringing the
protective outer stone and disappears
behind some trees he seems to have the
ability to travel through the channels
between the two worlds that coraline
can't see or perceive he literally knows
all the ins and outs of this world
suggesting that he's been traveling back
and forth for some time this is probably
the reason he was able to discover when
coraline's parents were kidnapped by the
beldan after mr and mrs jones go missing
he greets coraline on her bed as she
wakes up and coaxes her to follow him to
the hallway mirror where she can see
that her mom and dad are trapped beyond
a foggy glass she asks if he knows where
they are and he blinks at her as if to
say yes this is something that happens a
few times the cat blinks to say yes when
in the real world there's actually a
little easter egg at the beginning of
the movie to reference this which i
don't think i've mentioned before i'm
just looking for an old well
know it
as they cross back into the other world
coraline tells a story about bravery in
which her father protected her from a
swarm of wasps when she was younger the
cat asks if that's why she's going back
to try to save them seemingly not really
understanding the point of the story
this may be playing on the idea of cats
often being depicted as timid they are
the inspiration for slang terms used to
describe a timid person like scaredy cat
or pussycats knowing what the other
mother truly is the cat will go in and
out of the other world but doesn't seem
keen on confronting her himself as they
cross the threshold coraline remarks
that her companion is talking again how
fortunate i am said the cat in having a
traveling companion of such wisdom and
intelligence its tone remained sarcastic
but its fur was bristling and its brush
of a tail stuck up in the air the two
were entering the lair of the beast
if you want the true dark twisted world
of coraline the best way to experience
it is with the audiobook which you can
find narrated by coraline's legendary
author neil gaiman on audible this way
you know every line is being told
exactly the way the author intended it
audible offers an incredible selection
of audiobooks across every genre
including lots of more you also discover
exclusive audible originals from top
celebrities comedians renowned experts
podcasters i could go on but the point
is you'll never run out of hands-free
eyes free entertainment in your head
members get a free title every month
that no one can ever take from you even
oma
this month i'm checking out american
psycho by brett easton ellis now you
might think that i'm listening to it to
see how it compared with the movie and
yeah that's exactly why i chose it to
try out audible premium plus free for 30
days visit
audible.comworld or text cz's worlds to
500 500 you'll find that link in the
description audible.com
cz's world
the cat disappears for a little while
while coraline is speaking to the other
mother it's pretty clear that this is
because the two are enemies he avoids
her for most of the story but he's also
quite familiar with her enough to
suggest that she's probably trying to
lure coraline in because she wants
something to love or possibly something
to eat he also knows that she can't
resist a good game and suggests that
coraline challenge her to one to win
back her parents this is another reason
why i think he must have had his own
encounter with her in the past he also
recommends that coraline get some sleep
ahead of the long day tomorrow and
that's exactly what she does before she
gets up the next morning the other
mother goes out to try to fix up the
secret passageways that the cat uses to
enter and exit her world this tells me
that the beldem and the cat's fear of
each other may be mutual after all the
belldem's true form is a spider-like
creature and cats are known to eat
spiders there are multiple occasions
where she refers to the cat as vermin
it's also possible that she's just
trying to seal up the entryways because
her minions are rats and other species
that cats are known to devour when
coraline goes outside that morning she
runs into her furry friend its first
stood straight out from its body and its
eyes were wide while its tail was down
between its legs it did not look a happy
cat it sounds to me like he's very much
on edge when he's in the other world as
coraline explores the cat explains that
there's nothing to find outside of the
house because the bell dam hasn't
bothered to create it this line is
obviously book only as the garden is a
more important location in the movie and
the 2009 game together they loop all the
way around the small world back to the
house which the cat describes using an
analogy to a spider web spider's webs
only have to be big enough to catch
flies again this demonstrates
familiarity with the ancient antagonist
she hasn't yet revealed her spidery true
form to coraline the cat is unimpressed
with the beldam's attempts to keep it
out he also claims that there are ways
in and out that she does not know about
he also catches a rat and explains that
they're spies for her he tortures the
rat before eating it adding that some
people see the tendency of a cat to play
with its prey as a merciful one because
sometimes the prey will get away this
analogy is no mistake he's suggesting
that coraline's game of hide and seek
with the beldam could result in her
getting away if she plays her cards
right the cat then disappears behind a
tree to presumably eat the rats or
deposit it somewhere in the real world
at this point the cat kind of disappears
for most of the rest of coraline's game
against the other mother we don't know
if he's hiding away from his evil
adversary or just keeping an eye on
coraline's progress from a distance her
goal is to find the souls of three ghost
children and her parents and she's
managed to recover two of the three
souls but the leader of the rats who
i'll just call the big rat is in the
process of getting away with a third
what the cat does is the perfect analogy
of why coraline is definitely part of
the horror genre he catches the rat in
his sharp teeth decapitates it and stops
the soul marble with one paw this one is
toned down a little bit in the movie but
the film has no shortage of horrifying
moments of its own i don't like rats at
the best of times but this one was
sounding an alarm the cat is unsurprised
to learn that the beldam doesn't plan to
let them go even if horline finds her
parents to win the game he's also the
first to notice that the house is losing
its 3d form and flattening out into a
crude drawing coraline thanks him for
his help and says they can leave and
she'll see him back at home but he tells
her that the ways in and out of this
world are gone which seems to be very
unsettling for him coraline tries to pet
him and realizes that he's trembling and
his heart is beating hard so she
promises to bring him home with her and
it carries him into the house where the
other mother is waiting the cat stiffens
upon seeing her coraline tricks the
other mother into opening up the
passageway in between the two worlds the
link between worlds if you will in order
to prove that her parents aren't there
coraline has a plan but the cat clearly
isn't in on it she does her best elinity
and throws the cat at the other mother
it lands on her head and flails at her
with claws and teeth as coraline grabs
the snow globe containing her real
parents the cat bites the bell down's
cheek and draws the black tarry blood
that flows within her after throwing a
claw to her face he joins coraline in a
sprint to the corridor that bridges the
two worlds and after slamming the door
on their enemy urges coraline to run
with him the last words he would ever
say to her out loud they get back to the
jones family's drawing room where
coraline apologizes for throwing him and
he seems to accept this apology by
purring licking her finger and falling
asleep in her lap he wakes up before
coraline and waits by the door when
coraline's parents come inside in order
to quickly run away before they can do
or say anything i'm guessing he didn't
want to take any chances with how they'd
react to an unfamiliar animal in their
house or he just didn't trust any
creature vaguely resembling coraline's
mother at this point can you really
blame him again the cat disappears for a
week the time that coraline spends
defeating the beldam's dismembered hand
that had scuttled its way into the real
world when they saw each other again the
cat winked at her and rolled onto his
back allowing coraline to scratch the
fur on his belly through their journey
together the two had become friends the
witch had found her cat and more
importantly coraline kind of has someone
more suitable to spend time with now
wibby is not in the book at all so she
has no one to play with or talk to and
the other adults in her world don't
really listen to her i think that's part
of what made the other world where the
cat could talk so appealing to coraline
at the beginning of the story but as she
learned she doesn't need verbal cues to
communicate with this animal and that's
the end of the cat's story in the book
in the movie things are a bit different
because the cat seems to be attached to
yb in the beginning because he feeds it
and the final shot shows him
disappearing through one of the hidden
portals presumably back into the other
world which may have been reopened after
the belgium's defeat i talked about yb
the dam coraline and others in their own
horror history episodes for all of my
coraline character breakdowns hit that
playlist on the left but first make sure
you subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
and select all notifications and i will
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive